يعني يمكن ان نسجل التاريخ بانك اسهمت
بشكل مباشر
باداره بعض عمليات المقاومه العراقيه شرف
لي هذا الادعاء
اذا ادعاء الحقيقي اذا كانت لي بصمه في
المقاومه العراقيه ويحق مشروع وبوش نفسه
الذي قاد الغزو العراق اعلن قال له احتلت
بلادي لقمت فاذا كان هذا القول يعني يرتب
لي شرف المشاركه في هذا الشرف لي
ومن خلال المعلومات التي تنقلها من صدام
حسين الى الخارج نعم
كان في معلومات هامه جدا تقول للتاريخ
بانه اثرت على الارض كنت تتابع تراقب
نتائج ذلك على الارض المعنويات بشكل كبير
جدا
ترفع المعنويات وكانت
يعني بعض المعلومات انه يطلب من الانفصال
المقاومه الابتعاد عن الفصائل المتشدده
لانه هذه وراءها ما وراءها بالفعل اثبتت
الاحداث انه ايران وحتى امريكا وراء بعض
الفصائل المشدده اللي ممكن انه يعني
تسيطر على عمليات المقاومه وتظهرها بمظهر
مختلف
العراقيون
قتل الناس وضرب القوات الامريكيه وهي يعني
موجوده اثناء بها بالاسواق او اللي راح
ترضى القوات الامريكيه وتوقع اكثر الخسائر
مفهوم ولكن صدام حسين لم يتوقع الغزو على
ما يبدو كما حصل يعني توقع ضربات مثل 91
او اكثر بقليل ولكن ليس بالحجم والطريقه
اللي حصل فيها
انا سالته قال احنا دوله من ضمن الدولي
[موسيقى]
الا بحسابات بسيطه جدا